thank you
thank you well we have we have to give
away 27 oscars three honorary Oscars
including a Lifetime Achievement Award
to 81 year old Dino De Laurentiis or as
Anna Nicole Smith would call him fresh
meat
so I'm pleased to introduce our first
presenter one of the stars of traffic
Catherine zeta-jones
good evening centuries before man knew
how to count the years he knew how to
draw pictures cavemen illustrated their
walls with their dreams
today's dreams are projected on the
walls of multiplexes illustrated by the
movies art directors whom we now honor
for best achievement in art direction
the nominees are
Tim Yip whose designs provided the
perfect setting for blending fantasy and
legend in Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
Michael Coren is the art direction and
Meredith Boswell the set decoration of
that Yuletide tale of dr. Seuss's How
the Grinch Stole Christmas arcamax
the art direction and Crispian solace
the set a creation that depicted the
glory of the Roman Empire in gladiator
Marting trials the art direction and Joe
courtier for the set decoration of the
pained and turbulent life of the Marquis
de Sade in quills out of a different
page of French history is the art
direction of genre baths and the set
decoration of France was Renoir fresco
that captured the culinary perfection of
Patel
and the Oscar goes to
Timmy eight for Crouching Tiger
this is the first Academy Award for
Tamiya he's also nominated for costume
design for Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
thank you very much this is the first
time in the Oscar a little bit nervous
first of all I have to thank for my
parents because they are not there I
hope that they they can listen to me
somewhere here because they are already
gone
and I want to friends my family support
what I am working on and slightly fun
thanks for any
you